this
is star talk cosmic query the fan
favorite
i got with me chuck nice chat hey neil
what's happening
we're always doing this we're doing it
with the cosmic queries we got
we got this you got to love it you got
people love cosmic queries and then
live
i love it but uh i will say that this
this episode i happened to monitor the
twitter and people have really
they are super excited about this
episode the topic is
grit and perseverance which is not just
what athletes have but anyone who
achieves and succeeds and
excels in life or anything else they
choose
generally it requires a little bit of
grit and perseverance and i don't i
don't think enough credit is given to
that
we we so often want to say oh they're
natural
right right and i think that's that
absolves us
from having to to believe you could
achieve it by working hard they'll just
say ah
they just got it for free basically just
by being born
right neither you nor an expert and i
are an expert on this but we do have
someone who is a friend of star talk
yes her second appearance angela
duckworth
angela hello i'm so happy to be called a
friend of star talk
very exciting i'm gonna put on my resume
oh you were on once and you agreed to
come back
that's sufficient to call you a friend
let's go
low bar as you can see the threshold is
not
yeah that's all right i'll take it so
you're a professor of psychology
university of pennsylvania
and you're author of an amazing book
called
grit the power and passion of
perseverance
love it and that changed the dialogue on
what it is to achieve
i remembered when the book came out and
everybody talked talking about it was in
the news
and you're also founder and ceo
of the character lab character lab
what is that what a great name you like
it i love that
name yeah i think people uh like
wonder about what character means but
let me just say what character lab is
it's a non-profit
we advance scientific insights that help
kids thrive
so we help scientists and educators
study and improve things like
grit but also gratitude growth mindset
curiosity
kind of everything that we think
aristotle meant when he said
that character is life that's well lived
so it's a little bit new it's a little
bit old-fashioned
and i like the term character but i
think it's a little out of fashion these
days to be honest
really you guys don't agree are you i
character as a
as a that's the thing what's your
character are you a
a gentleman and a lady yeah so i agree
the way that's sort of written in 19th
century literature it's a little out of
date
but if you if you update it and make it
real it's the lab part
just see there you go maybe it's maybe
it's my upbringing because
it was uh stressed highly in my home
the uh the condition of your character
being the thing that measures you as a
person
and where your value as a person is
found
it is found in your character that's how
i was raised that way so
that's right like how are you going to
show up in the world right right like
yeah
yeah no it resonates with me martin
luther king's speech says
oh my god your character that's right
yes we have martin luther king
quotes and you you know he liked the
word character because you used it more
than once
and the one that we have in the biggest
font is that
character plus intelligence those are
the true goals
of education uh and because you were
talking about talent just a moment ago
which is the foil i think for grit like
this is what i'm
not studying um i couldn't agree more
that character including your grit
and more you know these are all things
that matter for kids to
develop as they grow up sweet
so and also your co-host to the podcast
no stupid questions
so you're ideal for a cosmic queries
because you're not going to make
anything
in a second that is stupid you could
have just stupid questions
i like that just stupid questions
probably more fun
and back in 2017 you're a macarthur
fellow that's the genius fellow that are
so
widely written about people and it's a
huge chunk of money that you could like
go to the bahamas with it if you chose i
donated my uh
my macarthur to character lab because
you know honestly i don't know what
macarthur fellows do with their
money but um i kind of think it would be
gross to keep it do you think
it's a nice chunk of change you want to
do something right with it that's right
you don't just go to vegas yeah you need
to go to vegas
thereby being a reflection of your
character
like no kidding here like being the uh
you know titular head of character lab
there have been many times where i
thought like i want to say this i'm
going to do this i want to tweet this i
want to retweet like
and then i think but probably not the
best thing for the head of character lab
so you need an alter ego or something
you know i know yeah i need like a
secret
like alter identity angela devilsworth
you know yeah exactly exactly
so we we got this is a cosmic queries
and we solicited
questions on grit and perseverance and
right up your alley
and you and and chuck you said people
were just all in it
man i mean i you have really touched a
nerve
uh you know with the idea of um
what with your work on grit because
people are
not only just asking questions but then
people
were debating each other from the
questions that they asked online
and i've never seen that happen before
with the cosmic queries yeah oh gosh
now i'm really curious i want to know
what people are saying never never
created
dust stops even within the page right
with people asking questions it created
just
responses to the questions and that is
good it means that you are a catalyst
for conversation which is wonderful
i love the alliteration truck that was
beautiful so here we go
right let's do some let's do this and we
always start with a patreon patron
because they support us financially and
of course we'd be fools not to
so uh let's go with thomas
um ellen skis
ellen skis there you go
tommen thomas elinska says somehow i
doubt it but go on
i know i was like i'm not gonna try that
one yeah angela
thomas well you will see that a running
theme here in star talk is that i
butcher people's names oh that's good i
hope you're doing it indiscriminately
like you should
equally offend yeah i do everywhere yeah
exactly
everybody's name gets butchered and it's
you know it's yeah
i won't even say i won't go any further
uh it says hey dr
tyson and dr duckworth having served in
the army for four years
my fellow veterans have come to realize
the importance of resiliency
now as a psychology major who
what tools could i use to help others
transition successfully into the
civilian
mindset coming to you from
fort benning could
and that was not you know this is just i
dressed down a little bit for you guys
it was
it was the last thing in the draw cause
you haven't done laundry well you know
what i actually have
a lot of west point swag because i've
been working with uh
west point for i don't know 15 years or
something so yeah they should be right
there
yeah tax dollars at work here i wonder
if that question
relates to the fact that in the army you
are commanded to perform
right and someone is screaming at you
calling you a maggot
and you don't want to be a maggot
whereas in
regular life no one is calling you a
maggot unless that happens to chuck
like coffee absolutely
it's normally my father-in-law but it's
okay
i i i i think of it as a term of
endearment
so if if this if that force isn't
operating on you
can you i don't want to over interpret
his question but it seems to me
it's where you if a military person is
trying to
offer help to a civilian they're trying
to find ways that a civilian can get
motivated
perhaps from within yeah and if i'm
again like reading into thomas's
question just guessing
i think a lot of people have the
question when you move out of the
military into civilian life or you um
you know retire from a sports team or
any any of these major life transitions
where you were
gritty no doubt right in in something
how do you transfer that in in another
domain
um and uh and i think it is a good
question because i actually
don't think um you know being gritty
in one situation then everything changes
i don't think there's any guarantee that
you're especially going to be
you know passionate and persevering in
this next thing i mean it's not that you
change entirely i just think that
we come to rely a lot on those
structures and maybe this is what you're
getting at neil like you know the
military is so
structured so is by the way being a part
of a professional sports team and so are
a lot of other
professions that require a lot of grit
and when you take something
out of the discipline yeah and
discipline right and they're like there
are routines there are like
things that you don't have to like
invent entirely on your own i mean
getting up early isn't that hard when
you are part of active service right you
don't have to like think like how am i
going to get up early and like schedule
my day
um so i think it is a good question and
um if the advice is
like what could i as somebody who is
gritty and is in the military like say
to somebody who is transitioning or
maybe there are
maybe they're civilians and they've
never been military i always think
stories are that are the best way to do
it like
you know it's a it's a it's something
i've not
actually fully understood as a scientist
but there is something about the human
mind that learns from stories in a way
that we
and you tell me what you guys think like
that that we like we never forget them
like i hardly forget a story that
somebody
you know uh whereas statistics just run
through like water like a sieve
right and and and there's this kind of
um stickiness and sometimes you know
like there's a
there's a moral so we remember the story
but also the moral anyway i think
telling stories that are true
and that are maybe helpful to illustrate
you know times that you struggled with
resilience but like what you learned and
what worked for you so not just a story
in the abstract but a personal
experience story which makes presumably
makes it that much more real
what do you think about that though i
agree a lot more conversing than i do
entirely i think you just look back
you know when children sit in a circle
around a storyteller they are completely
wrapped
and you don't even need video for that
you can just sit there
and if you're a good storyteller you
just talk to them and they're wrapped
and the adult version of that is when
you go to the movies and someone is
telling you a story from the screen
so not only that the constellations of
the night sky
um i've studied them just because
they're fun to talk about when you have
a star party
but they're stories every constellation
has a story
and i was told i read that this was a
way
that you boosted um uh conversational
literacy
like you would just talk about this guy
and wherever you were the sky was with
you
and you'd be able to tell that to others
you mean like in ancient times
yeah ancient times of course okay yeah
without the apps that you look at the
app
and you hold up the app yeah in my day
we have to remember where the stars were
none of this
stuff
but um the mythologies were one way to
remember them was you put them in the
sky
and they're in the dome they're in your
cosmic dome every night
yeah and i think i think there's like an
emotion that comes with stories that
like never
really comes through with statistics and
then uh you know if you tell a story
about your own life there's
there's a little bit of a like people
can see themselves like
in your shoes so um
so yeah i have like i said i haven't
really impacted like all the
what are all the magic ingredients of
stories because they are magical
but uh i think we named a couple of them
yeah all right another question
okay here we go leslie goodwill of
patreon also wants to know uh she says
my daughter trinity asked
how the science of grit and perseverance
can relate to the cosmic perspective
what i feel like i should pass that
immediately to neil no no we have to tag
team this no no this is a tag team
question
so we have to figure out so first first
first so
let's break this down first is there a
way to encapsulate the
the science of grit yeah i should
probably start with that that's
part of the collaboration here right yes
yes okay um
so uh in a nutshell what i mean by grit
is this combination of of passion and
perseverance
for really long-term goals and i think
that's the part i really want to
emphasize not being like oh my god i
want to be a stand-up comic and i so
want to do it like
and that person's like staying up but
you know until four in the morning once
right like it's really like how do you
sustain
passion and perseverance for honestly
years or decades
because i just don't think anything
great ever happens overnight and that
that's the emphasis in grit on stamina
and people want something to happen
quickly
and grit is the opposite of that it's
recognizing that it takes long
investments yeah people aren't very good
at waiting
we all know that right like none of us
are you know
if any of us could have instant
gratification compared to delayed
gratification
we would all take instant gratification
i think if there were a shortcut to
you know world-class excellence i would
i would take it too
um but yeah that's just so completely
obvious when you when you
put it that way right it is actually
there's a data set on
about a thousand four-year-olds like all
over the country
where they were all given the choice
between uh like two treats say like
let's say marshmallows because that was
one of the
two famous marshmallow experiments it is
but here's the thing
tell it so so a lot of people saw this
um like on the colbert
report and like you know it's kind of
entered like sesame street's done stuff
on it so so a lot of people have heard
about the marshmallow test
the way the marshmallow test works is
yet uh like usually around a
four-year-old
preschool and they're sitting at a table
and
they're first given the selection of all
kinds of treats say they pick
marshmallows as their favorite you take
away all the other treats and then you
make two piles
say you have two marshmallows on the
right you got one marshmallow on the
left
and you just ask the little boy or girl
like would you rather have
two but you have to wait you know till i
come back in the room i gotta do
something
or one right away so it's two later
or one now and uh the the test part is
really like you see how long
that four-year-old can can really wait
it out versus
just basically you know eat the first
one right and then have
have one now and here's the thing
everybody
decides that they want to have two you
ask them like do you want to have two
later what everybody says i'll wait i'll
wait i'm good i'll definitely wait
and then the question is how long can
you wait so i think it's just
interesting that we would all prefer
to you know have more even if there's a
weight but i i think there's a um
you know inability to sustain that
so i can offer a cosmic reflection on
that
that's a kid test of course but you if
you raise that up to adult level
there's still that behavior manifested
maybe not with marshmallows but other
other trees lots of other things that we
have problems with
things that are so much better than
marshmallows
probably some of them are legal and
that's
a very good point only some of which are
legal
right um so i would say biologically
when i think about it there's all these
people who want to live forever
all right and i thought to myself do i
want to live forever
well if i live forever then i have no
motivation to do anything today
because i can always do it you can
always procrastinate yeah yeah it's
it and even procrastinators can say i'm
gonna
i i'll get around to it yeah i'll get
around to procrastinating later
um so so if you recognize
and if you're not shirley maclaine who
believes in multiple lives or
whole religions of course have these
foundations or
not just whether you're reborn but
whether you are
born on earth again whether you're in in
in
valhalla or heaven or anywhere else so
if you see your life as just
the days on this world
then and you know you are going to die
that creates a sense of urgency
to how you spend your time
not only let me take let me take another
step higher the number of people who
have ever been born
is small compared to the total genetic
combinations that can make an actual
human
and it will forever be a miniscule
fraction of a tiny fraction
a tiny fraction yeah so most people
who could ever exist will never
even be born right so so
to quote to quote um richard dawkins
we because we die
are the lucky ones because we are alive
at all
yes and so when it comes to
non-existence exposed to non-existence
never having existed so when i think of
what i'm gonna do today it is because
i exist i might not have ever existed
and my days on this earth are limited do
you really think about that like on uh
not daily not daily okay
that's interesting he thinks about it so
much that he's written a children's book
called you're gonna die
you're all gonna die you're all gonna
die now get something
done so
for me that can be a motivator for
anyone who fully embraces and
understands
that state of truth yes
yeah and and and i do think you're right
that kind of um you know let's just talk
about procrastination like yeah i'll get
to it and
and people procrastinate in small ways
like yeah they should get around to
something
and it they delay by a week but you're
right some people are delaying things by
like decades like
yeah i'm gonna get a job that i really
care about like you know
at some point and then and then years go
by
i think i think if you really thought
you were only gonna live for one day
right if today were the only day
then uh and you know that would create
an urgency just to like
i don't know what that would create an
urgency for but but yeah no i think
having a sense of mortality by the way
i think about my death a lot and um i
think
it's like but angela you need to see a
psychologist
no i think it's very healthy i actually
try to remind other people of death
like a lot maybe not weekly but um you
know especially when i start like a new
collaboration or if i meet somebody that
i really want to work with i'm like all
right hi my name is angela
like here's why i'm reaching out to you
you're gonna die
so am i very quickly i mean i'm not
exactly sure when
we should work on this together like i
literally say that in opening emails it
doesn't always work but i
i had been to probably too many you know
zoom services like memorial services
during this
pandemic and i was just at one yesterday
and it was a great life it was the guy
who the scientist behind the ten
thousand hour rule the
deliberate practice was a beautiful like
celebration but he he
you know died in his very early 70s and
was very
unexpected and sudden and you could say
like it was tragic
but i remember when i well it was
yesterday i was like
they're weeping with everyone else and i
was thinking you know
whether it's 72 or maybe 92 or whatever
it is a
blink of an eye and so i
i think actually keeping that in
perspective like i don't know i think
it's very helpful
i i'm glad we agree and that's our
collaborative project that we just
concluded
yeah exactly yeah we got to take our
first break there you go ladies and
gentlemen
this episode of death talk has been
brought to you by dr angela duckworth
and dr neil degrasse tyson
great we gotta we gotta take a quick
break when we come back more
on breaking down the anatomy of grit and
perseverance on cosmic queries
star talk we're back
star talk cosmic queries grit and
perseverance determination angela
duckworth
literally and figuratively wrote the
book on this
and just before the break you mentioned
that you attended a memorial service
by the guy who wrote about the ten
thousand hours just remind us what the
10 000 hours is
so there's a a an idea that to become a
world-class expert
at anything you know chess ballet
astrophysics
um you need to put in say 10 000
hours i mean i say that in air quotes
i'll unpack it in a second 10 000 hours
of practice
and and that's i think almost become you
know almost like part of common
culture right that like the ten thousand
hour rule is the rule of becoming great
um is the journalist who wrote about it
but the scientist behind that
research was named andres erickson and
he passed away and his his um
memorial service was yesterday and i was
a collaborator and a friend of his
and i i think one of the things that
anders would want everyone to know
is that it does take thousands and
thousands of hours of practice to become
great his
own brother said during his memorial
service that if you added up the number
of hours this guy spent
on the science of expertise it easily
would have exceeded 100
000 hours um but what anders would
really want everyone to do that's very
meta to say
he spent at least 10 000 hours trying to
prove that 10 000 hours would make you
an expert it was so meta
i mean actually in his own family but
also among friends and colleagues we
used to just all joke that he was the
world expert on world experts i mean
super meta right and then he had and he
actually did all the things that he
studied it was meta meta meta
but uh but but here's the thing that i
think a lot of people don't appreciate
which is that it's the quality of the
practice that really
uh distinguishes experts i mean
obviously it's the quality and the
quantity
but what experts do with those hours is
different from what other people do
so so it's not just let me get in the
water and slap
and slap my hands to try to swim let me
improve the
stroke i mean i think built into the
concept of practice is you're trying to
get better at it you're not just doing
it
so it's 10 000 hours of improving
yourself not 10
000 hours of just doing it okay well you
guys have just hit upon a really great
point i'm going to interrupt them
and and throw in two questions because
they're so
apropos to what you just said in a in a
different way but still
uh kunal uh kahana
from facebook says does perseverance
really lead to success and when should
a scientist slash person slash
athlete know when to quit
that's one that's one like that one
that's just one long one that was a long
one you tell me the next one i'm gonna
forget the first one
no you're not gonna because here's the
just remember when is it when where
should i when did you quit
and then nathan warden along the same
lines okay you guys can combine this
uh there's a saying you can run a donkey
around the track and train them hotter
than any racehorse that's ever been
trained but it'll never win the kentucky
kentucky derby is there a limit to the
amount of success
that we can expect from grit when
competing so that goes to what you guys
just finished saying about
how to train how to practice but then
the second part of that
is okay you're doing all the right
things is
there a point where you should say
enough is enough i'm going to quit chuck
that donkey would win the kentucky derby
of donkeys of donkeys
and nobody wants that that is not
making it onto espn nobody wants to be
the fastest ass
on the court okay they're worse things
that you could be but
definitely not the fastest burrow okay
um
okay so so are you guys watching you
already watched the last dance
right oh the michael jordan thing yeah
yeah i've seen four episodes yeah did
you stop are you not working to watch
the rest of it
angela i'm a busy man okay like you
don't have to like
share priorities here you don't have to
like i'm only on episode two i'm not
going to shame you
binge shame me we're seeing only
four out of eight well i'm having a hard
time delaying gratification because
every time i start watching
it all i want to do is just watch it all
the way through so actually
it's okay anyway the reason i bring it
up is because people ask the question
if i trained for 10 or 20 000 hours like
could i ever be michael jordan
right and i think for most people it
doesn't take much thinking to think like
nope
would definitely not be michael jordan
even if i trained for a hundred thousand
hours right so
i i disagreed a little bit with anders
on this we had many spirited
conversations
but i do believe that there are
abilities that are not uh
you know like equally distributed you
know between all of us like
anybody could be michael phelps anybody
could be katie ledecky anybody could be
fill in the blank um i think anders may
have been a little more skeptical that
there really are things as like talents
that you know
really limit what we can do i think what
we agreed on
is that people are so so far away from
their potential
that it's just like this hypothetical
that they throw out they're like what
what if i you know what if i really
worked really hard but
but i i think it i think if you're not
even approaching that hypothetical limit
in your actual life it's it's a kind of
silly almost like
so angela so not to put words in your
mouth but you're are you saying
that if you are i agree entirely that
it's it's a
it's a false comparison to say
if i work hard at best will i ever be as
good as michael jordan what they should
be asking is
if i work harder than i am at any of
these other hundred things
will i get much much better at it yes
then i was
right because like you know like the the
the comparison between you and other
people which is by the way totally
natural we all do it
is not as useful as the comparison of
you and yourself
right you could be to what you could be
work on what you do to what you want to
be
to what you were to today to tomorrow
all those comparisons i think are very
useful
the other ones are less useful
okay so when should you give up oh yeah
the quit question
i um i think there's there are occasions
where we should give up the the times
that we should give up are
when there's something better you can do
right i mean it's kind of that simple
um in economics they call it like
opportunity cost right like when the
opportunity cost succeed right
so should i be doing this podcast
anymore i was like i don't know maybe
maybe there's something better you could
do
right um i i think that's giving up
you know on a good day right it's like
you know i've been thinking about it and
so i got one i got one angela so i have
a cameo
in ice age five
you are what animal are you okay i'm a
weasel
so now the critics said
of ice age five by the way you didn't
know there were four of them
yeah my kids are a little too old for
that neither did i know that there were
four when i was left
so one of the critics said um ice age
fives makes it clear
that this franchise should have gone
extinct a long time ago
that's a good line i love that one that
was telling them they should quit
they haven't made another one since oh
maybe yeah maybe the critic finally got
so
i mean look there are times where you're
like instead of making ice age six like
maybe there's something better we could
do
right like that that really is always
the rational answer the thing
that i also study though is like giving
up too early
you know there are people who like you
know that initial discouragement right
you know one thing that happens in life
and you guys are both
successful that you know that was
flattery but it was sincere
but you know you you you get into like
bigger and bigger ponds
right and like suddenly you're not the
biggest fish in the pond anymore you're
in a much bigger pond that's what it
means to be successful is to move up
like that
that initial drop in your ego it almost
feels like the bottom of your stomach
falls
it's like it's like oh wait i'm not the
special shiny
one i think a lot of people quit then
right and like i think that's
too early to quit like you just
transition into you know west point
which i studied for
you know more than a decade and that
initial kind of like you are not number
one you're not even number two
half of the people are below average
right can you can you not quit
no everyone's above average angela
that's lake wobegon that's not uh
that's not less boys so
so i think you i think there are times
you should quit you should quit when
there's something better you can do but
i don't always think that we're an
emotionally
like uh clear-eyed frame of mind to make
those
decisions and and so i i also think we
should be careful not to quit too early
good one you know that's great and i i
think your um
your economic analogy of opportunity
cost
is really um very useful because
when the cost of doing something
uh greatly outweighs the benefits
gleaned from doing it or the returns on
it or the returns
it's it's no longer enjoyable and so
what you've done is taken that from a
numbers standpoint and put it into human
terms
basically look if this is like not
fun and you're not getting anything out
of it and you're not getting any better
and you're never going to be what
it is time maybe it's time
yeah yeah absolutely i think that's
exactly what it comes down to
all right awesome give me some more all
right here we go this is eric varga from
facebook
and eric says hello dr tyson and dr
duckworth
i am a middle grade science and social
studies
teacher congratulations are good for you
definitely
one of the greatest issues facing our
education system is the stigma
surrounding
failure and intelligence every year i
and my colleagues have students that
help
that we help overcome learning uh
learned helplessness
what are some of the best practices that
teachers and school systems can
implement that could help students
achieve success
beyond the framework of standardized
tests thank you so much so angela this
sounds like it's right
this sounds like it's right down the
center line of your project
for which you're ceo of character
building
i mean what's the term chucky used uh
um there's a term there failure he said
that
uh the stigma surrounding failure and
intelligence
and learned helplessness is learned
helps helplessness
angela what is learned helpless yeah
i'll zone in on that like i'll just
zoom in i guess i'll zoom in on that so
one of the scientific advisors to
character lab uh this non-profit i um
help run
is marty seligman and he coined the term
learned helplessness
about 50 years ago so marty's a
psychologist
who um was at the time he was studying
dogs and
he was doing these random assignment
experiments where for example
some dogs got painful electric shocks
and they had a harness but they had a
button in front like a panel
that if they leaned forward far enough
their button would touch the panel
and then the panel would just like
terminate the shock so you couldn't
control that the shocks were going to
start
but you could end them right so that's a
group of dogs then there was another
group
this is 50 years ago when you could do
experiments like that you know he's a
total dog lover i have to say there's
like
i can't even like explain these studies
about pita pita wasn't invented yet
but it was okay because they got a treat
i don't even know if they got no i'm
totally sure they did yeah
that would be that would confuse the
actual experiment but yeah exactly
they'd be like
we can't do that um you know marty would
point out by the way that these were
not harmful they were just painful
so anyway i don't know if that makes it
feel any better
uh but um but innocent thousand volt
shocks that's all
yeah he might also point out that like
lots of people are doing these studies
but anyway
um these dogs so the point is that these
dogs there's another group of dogs
that are what's called yoked to the
first group of dogs and that means that
they
are experiencing the same pattern of
shock so the same schedule
so when the shock goes on in one cage it
goes on the other then when one dog with
the harness and the button
turns it off that other dog is sitting
in another cage can't see the first dog
but like all of a sudden the shot goes
off
so if you're in that second group all
you experience is like shock comes on
shot goes off shock comes on shot goes
off you have no control
and what marty discovered is that the
dogs in the cages that had no control
over even terminating the shock right
they have no control over anything just
like bad stuff happens
seemingly at random they developed
learned helplessness they had a kind of
um
basically it was like dog depression
right like they
they weren't eating right they weren't
sleeping right and the most important
thing was
when you put the dog that just has had
this experience of like
things happen to you you can't control
them you give them another situation
you put them in a different cage and you
allow them to actually
you know escape the shock because you
know you unharness them yet
they they kind of like lie down and they
don't they don't try
and that was learned helplessness you
learn that you're helpless
and i think a lot of teachers like
middle school teachers
they see this happening you know not
with electric shocks
but they see kids fail things and then
for the kids they learn that they can't
do anything they're like look i
like i can't do math i'm not like a math
person it's just like it's just
impossible
it's clear that angela is making the
case for electric shocks in elementary
school
which by the way what you said i just
said that i am a hundred percent
foreign
it is about time
you guys have just arranged this whole
episode so that you can um
where do we get the vest that's what
you want to order them immediately but
no that's um that's what it means such a
thing exists
yeah and that's yeah i mean have you
guys ever felt that way about anything
or maybe not because maybe you are more
like the resilient
you know uh like individuals that marty
has studied like do you do you
identify at all with that story are you
kind of like oh yeah i kind of felt like
that once or not
i feel helpless on twitter just learned
helplessness
it's funny
i think i think it's very interesting
that you the way
it's the way the experiment is presented
you know um it's persistent
and pervasive i think everybody
you know about marty's research if
you're if you're if you're you're using
marty's words right like that that like
when adversity happens and you perceive
it to be persistent like
this is not ending and pervasive it's
like it's like it
it seems like everything in your life is
going wrong i mean and those are really
like
the cognitive hallmarks of depression
right you're like i can't do anything
it's everywhere it's everything it's not
gonna end right um because i think we
all have that experience in some way
but what gives us the ability to take
charge or to say that we will change is
that
um we don't have the overwhelming
depression uh but we're not bearing that
like
there's nothing i can do we actually
because and also
we've also had successes in the past and
i think i think that is really
truly like you know i don't want to
oversimplify things
but like small mastery experiences like
small wins
i mean just to answer this eighth grade
teachers uh and
you know question a little more directly
like you know took a little i took a
little bit of the long route getting
there
but i really do think you have to
engineer like small wins
for young people so that but angela
they've already done that and it's
handing out trophies for everything
i am not a big fan of like participant
trophies but
this is what it is it's it's there are
no losers everyone is a winner
i can guess how you feel about that oh
this is awesome you guys are
are you guys maybe i mean no no no no
i'm not talking about i think you're
like telepathically connected to these
questions
oh is that like the next thing here's
the here let's go into the next question
what chuck will do exactly that when we
come back for the third and final
segment
of stark talk the grit edition
when we return
we're back star talk cosmo aquarius the
great edition
with angela duckworth one of the world's
experts i'm gonna say the world's expert
would you agree chuck
i would indeed if you wrote this one not
so what do you do you just before the
break you mentioned
that small successes
yeah can help prevent you from falling
into some
kind of achievement funk where you might
think that you will never achieve
but in the limit of that you're getting
trophies and medals and
you're getting complimented under
circumstances that
in a previous generation would have
never been warranted so chuck you had a
question that was exactly that
yes what was the question uh you guys
really teed up
uh miriam uh
masarikova masarikova miriam masarikova
says
wants to know this hey dr tyson hey dr
duckworth
i'm wondering if there is any
relationship between
grit and self-esteem
so now this goes to small wins um
participation trophies and you know is
is is there
something to do with how you feel about
yourself
that propels you to keep going all right
so
here's the answer i think grit is more
related to self-efficacy
than self-esteem and i think this is the
difference between getting participant
trophies for being like
8th out of 8th or like anything you do
like you know your parents give you a
standing ovation i don't believe in any
of that
you know that is all about like let's
see
i do i have a 19 year old well almost 19
and uh let's just say 18 and 17. so did
you give them standing ovations for
their school play
i am pretty sure that if my girls came
in here like they would tell you that i
was
the opposite of the parent who was like
everything is great
you're perfect that's like what
grandparents do but
but but i did actually experience this
with them because they would also be
you know living american life and like
there would be
eighth place ribbons for being eighth
out of eighth which i didn't
think was necessary or helpful um but i
think the difference is this
right when i say small wins i'm not
saying like praise your kid for drinking
their orange juice in the morning what
i'm saying is
if you have a kid who's struggling let's
say with math or
you know foul shots whatever it is
they're struggling you know a great
parent and a great coach and a great
teacher they all do the same thing which
is they figure out
what is a challenge that is smaller than
the one that this kid consistently fails
that is a stretch but that they they're
likely to be able to master with some
support and there was this a russian
uh psychologist named vygotsky who
thought that that was basically the
recipe for
development through childhood which is
that you're a little kid you're three
years old you can't reach something
but with a little bit of assistance you
might be able to reach just this much
higher
and that's that's the thing that you
need to do you have to like break down
things that students are not doing well
consistently into smaller
more manual parts this means as a
teacher or as a coach
you actually have to get to know your
students and not
work you have to work for that angelo
i mean yeah i know this is a lot of work
yeah the next thing you'll be telling me
is that i need to parent my children
instead of just letting the tablet do it
yeah i know right it's getting starting
to be unreasonable right oh yeah don't
be unreasonable
i mean it's not only a lot of work i
have to say it takes a lot of skill i
remember
um listening to this um interview with a
u.s
olympic uh like gymnast gymnastic
coach right and i'm sorry that i can't
remember the name it wasn't like bella
corolla or anything but um
but uh the the interviewer said like
what is the secret to
like training these you know um athletes
to like olympic gold medals and they
were like the secret to everything
is to be able to break things down and
then break them down again and then
break them down again so that it
so that so it's tractable right and i
think that's
that that will lead to self-efficacy
which is the belief that you can do
something if you try
as opposed to self-esteem which is that
you are
just great like you know like and i
think that's a big very important
excellent very good excellent excellent
well i got to tell you
i i just wish angela was like every
guest that we ever have because every
time you say something
it leads to another question which means
i don't know no one's ever going to
believe that i don't actually know these
questions
i know it's amazing it's amazing i love
it all right so kara clay from facebook
says
uh what does the science say about grit
in different generations popular
opinions suggest that young people
whether we define them as millennials or
gen z or even younger lack the
resilience of older generations
but is it really true that's right so
they don't
know where they used to and if so get
off my lawn
you don't get off my lawn i'm older
back in my day is it because society is
changing
or it's because grit is developed
and fine-tuned over one's lifetime and
therefore younger people will always
appear to be
less resilient regardless of
the generational identity right so
that'd be a delusion of older people
that they had grit
when the younger generation doesn't
right angela what is it
yeah and by the way it's dr kara blakely
from ohio who goes
i was gonna say doctor like this is a 10
out of 10 question i was like they
should just get a little prize for
having such a sophisticated
thoughtful question which almost answers
itself right because it says look
there's two possibilities right right if
you grew up in the 50s
you know culturally you know maybe
you're different
right than somebody who grew up in you
know the millenniums the millennials
right
but but here's the answer the short
answer is nobody knows because i don't
have a time machine and i
i can't go back and measure these
generations of people who came before us
that's a really short answer i don't
know
right but the longer answer is that um
it's it's it's scientists are debating
like how much of
like people's personalities is
generational right so there is this idea
of generation me like
narcissistic you know inflated
self-esteem etc
but there are scientists who are on both
sides of this debate um
and they publish papers saying their own
sides
my guess is though in terms of this
you know what's the ratio you say there
are generational changes which i just
told you like i can't go back in time
and measure but let's assume that there
are um my guess is that more of it
is from maturation than from
core you know like the decade that you
were born in um and it is really hard
to be 50 which is how old i am and like
look at a 20 year old
and it's really hard to remember what i
was like when i was 20.
so so often we're like god what's wrong
with you you know
you grew up in the wrong generation but
really they're just 20. they're like
literally half your age less than half
your age
right right right it is funny i
remembered thinking when i was 21. yeah
i was badass
and now i look back and i didn't know
[ __ ] about anything right i mean like
most of us were just total idiots when
we were younger but we forget
i no i think they're right well it's a
fantastic question i have to i know
i have to just i would like to just put
a little gold star next to that question
thank you carol
clay or doctor and karen with that
gold start you'll do even better next
time
you've been encouraged to take that
little increment another step we want to
see an even more sophisticated question
next time
absolutely all right let's move on to
ursula lawrence
did either of you ever learn to grit it
out as a child
or did that come later on now i asked
this
for selfish reasons one
uh i grew up under the
auspices of tough it out
all right wait you're now speaking
personally you're not is that you or the
person
this is me personally that's why i'm
asking no this is why i'm asking
ursula's question because i want to know
if my parents were bad parents
and am i a bad parent because i was
raised that way
i am a tough-it-out kind of parent which
means if it ain't that bad
you need to handle it on your own don't
come to me
that's the way my parents did now people
when i say that to people
what's wrong with you other parents at
the park look at me like i am
out of my freaking gourd because
give me an example chuck give me an
example and also like how old is the
kid all right six years old
girl okay i am a proponent of
of of reinforcing that she is able to
do whatever she wants to do and that
means
i cannot come to her aid every single
time she is having difficulty
yes so she's climbing the wall at the
park they have a rock climbing wall
okay she gets up to a certain point and
i notice she always stops and comes back
down
i know it's because she's afraid to go
any higher than that
yeah so i go over and i say you know you
can make that
right you can go ahead and you can make
that well go up to the top and cut my
hand i can't do that but you can make
that go ahead and do it
i'm telling you we we have some push
back back and forth because i'm she's
scared
she does it and then she's like i did it
like right yeah right now
when when the pushback was happening the
other moms were looking at me like
oh he's one of those yeah he's one of
those like pushy
um sports dads he's
yeah yeah and they were tasting and they
were
me and they were like looking and then
and and you know
plus i'm the only black dude there and
[Laughter]
so they were trying not to look like
they were just disking right right yeah
so secretly just disking from the fact
that that's what was done to me
yeah i mean demanding is good uh you
know obviously
so that story tells me that you know you
weren't asking your daughter to do
something which
was impossible right like you're asking
your daughter to go just a little
farther than she was comfortable
and you knew that without you you know
encouraging her like like she wouldn't
and i think that's exactly what this
russian psychologist bogotsky meant is
that kids need to be asked to do things
that are just
like just beyond their reach and
vygotsky also said
it's like just what you like can't you
do but if you had
support you would be able to do right so
just you know
imagine the visual picture of your
six-year-old daughter
trying to reach something right and it's
four inches away
but you give her her like it's just a
little boost and i think that's what and
then they
then they're like oh i can do it and and
vygotsky
well it was russian but the term
translate would be like scaffolding
like that's what parents are there to do
to be demanding but also to provide
you know the the support just so that
it's not it's not impossible
and i i agree with you you know the one
thing about parents judging other
parents
is that from the outside you can't
really tell whether somebody's being
you know too demanding not demanding
enough
you know they just not enough
information so if i just saw you in the
park
parenting your little girl honestly i
wouldn't be able to tell you what
parenting style you had because there's
too much like context and so forth
but as a parent you yourself know
everything and i think you just have to
ask yourself like
am i being demanding enough and am i
being supportive enough
so so the key point here is chuck knew
that this little increment that her
daughter
his daughter was afraid of that she
could do it if she tried
it was not an impossible test it wasn't
you know grow wings and fly
fly to the top it was this little extra
increment which
became that much more of an achievement
for her the fact that you didn't help
her
right right exactly and that's the
difference between that and a
participant ribbon also right because
that's just giving
a person a ribbon for not stretching
right
and it makes all the difference right so
getting back to the question
i would say for me i didn't need grit
in doing what i love to do which is uh
physics
yeah yeah just science cosmetics you
didn't have to use discipline because
you just wanted to do it
yeah i just wanted to do it i derived
pleasure from the act of doing it and
learning more
so at no time could i or would i have
ever
called that grit there are other things
that i had a really hard
job one summer when i was in high school
i wasn't paid very much
a camp junior counselor but we did all
kinds of other things and it was
it was a nightmare but i thought i
realized that there's a point where it
ends you know the summer ends the days
go by i felt like
the prisoner putting x's on the calendar
you know there's a point
where this ends and so i needed
something well let me let me
you can use the word grit however you
want honestly but like
when i say grit the reason i say passion
and perseverance is that i really do
think
that gritty people they're not using a
lot of self-control to do what they're
doing they're doing it because they do
love it
for me grit is something goes wrong
and do you recover from that
no i don't want to define a word that
you wrote a book on but
you can do that i mean i i think that's
like stamina isn't it is like you know
keeping going when you're not you know
when things are going wrong
and it's like staying engaged i mean you
know like isaac newton
and einstein they both said that like
the behind their
genius they probably didn't say it was
genius but whatever like behind their
accomplishments that was that they were
still trying to solve the same problems
and to your point that only happens when
you intrinsically are interested
um all i really mean by grit is the
sustained
you know over time part also i used to
wrestle i wrestled for like eight years
of my life
and that is the single hardest physical
thing
i've ever done and so and by the way
anyone who has wrestled will say exactly
that same sentence
if you haven't wrestled does that count
emotionally like when you've wrestled
with things emotionally
like like i have for so very long
or wrestled with what to order for lunch
or all kinds of wrestling
i've wrestled a lot of things yeah i
don't know if i don't know if it's the
same we have to ask angela about that
right but i just i just know that i um
if you've never wrestled and you've done
any other sport you could list
a dozen other sports there but if you've
wrestled your answer will be wrestling
and i've done that experiment and it's
really there so in terms of just the
physical exhaustion
and the physical the how fits you have
to be what would your life be like if
you hadn't wrestled
like what's going to get that yeah good
question there are many places i would
have just given up
because i said i don't have the energy
to complete this
even though you loved what you did
because no no for other things where
let's say
there's things sometimes you have to do
if you don't completely love it right
that's what i wanted to say so that so
even though you love what you do
so much right there's some things where
you're like oh god i want to give up or
like oh
for example do this i'm going to quote a
famous writer who i don't remember who
said
i like having written oh yeah
it's uh you know what writers say those
things all the time
all they're always whining about how
hard it is right so they're just i mean
i had a
i wrote a column every month for natural
history magazine damn near killed me
yeah the deadline just creeps up it's
like what about your
boosters how about your how about the
how about your best-selling book how
much work was that
uh that was um a collection of essays i
had written
but i remembered the effort of every
single sentence and the choice of words
and and now i step back and look at yeah
that works
together there and that's that's a thing
that what was a bigger effort was my war
book
which i had a co-author with 600 pages
and it was 10 years
in the writing and he said yourself this
will never get finished this will never
get done
of course having done a phd thesis that
also has a never-ending
feel to it so that's a
uh so was wrestling helpful during this
like yes
yes yes even when i'm not actually
wrestling so i think the
the idea that you're in a struggle and
you overcome the struggle
and it's one of the great struggles of
your life i agree with
chuck that it can apply in other
dimensions
to what the challenges are in your life
and that's then i've done that so that's
how
that's how i think that's why i think
that's why uh parents send their kids to
you know do hard things not that they
think they're going to be like
professional wrestlers for example for
example
or professional or whatever but
challenges challenges of life it's
challenges yeah
yeah i agree i'm reminded of don quixote
where where there are or at least in
manila mancha the broadway musical in
the song
to to reach the unreachable star
to move the immovable object to fight
the unbeatable foe
that if you if you have if you have
struggled and you know what it is to
struggle
even if you do not see the end in sight
you can
tap that source of energy and
inspiration and emotion
to keep you going because you might
succeed right you can learn to strive
right yes there you go that's the way
that's it what a great that's very
poetic i love it
learn to start to make into a broadway
musical
we gotta we gotta we gotta wrap this up
but i don't truck i don't think we have
time for any more questions
no we don't but i gotta tell you
something one two three
four i still have five pages
five pages that means we come back to
this topic
if angela deigned to grant us another
they keep you out of the lab neil and
you'll be like god damn it
named burden duckworth we will totally
bring her back because this is a very
important subject for parents for
people who want to succeed people trying
to get out of the doldrums
so angela always good to have you i get
to say that because it's our second
because we're like friends
we're totally there always good to have
you chuck
you're there for us always all right man
i'm neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist as always
bidding you
to keep hooking up